we would now like to compare the moment
of inertia for a rigid body let's take
an arbitrary rigid body about the center
of max mass so let's say the rigid body
is rotating about this axis and what we
like to compare that is to the moment of
inertia say about a parallel axis that's
also going through the rigid body now
let's recall how we define moment of
inertia we first choose a mass element
DM what I like to show is if this object
is rotating about this axis then what is
that object do it
well that object is undergoing a little
bit of circular motion and this distance
here is what we call the perpendicular
distance about that axis and let's
indicate this is for our element DM so
this perpendicular distance is what
shows up in our definition for the
center of mass moment of inertia about
that axis it's the integral of DM RCM
perp now again quantity squared what is
this distance this is the perpendicular
distance from our DM to the axis of
rotation imagine it's doing a circle and
that's the radius of that circle so if
we were to calculate the moment of
inertia about another axis then about
this axis the perpendicular distance
here that I'll write as R s perp and you
can see these perpendicular distances
are not the same and the moment of
inertia about that other axis is equal
to the integral of DM r s perp quantity
squared now how do we relate those
perpendicular distances well there's a
couple of ways to do it and notice that
the distance between these axes is given
by D and I'm gonna call this the
distance R cm now let's just call this
the X direction
I'll call that
so how do I relate these distances well
D is a fixed distance and you can see
from my diagram that RS perp is equal to
D plus R cm x and if i square this i get
d squared plus 2d r cm x plus r cm x
squared and that are cm x squared is
precisely what we're calling the
perpendicular distance so when I put
those into my moment of inertia is I get
DM times d squared plus 2 D times R cm x
plus these parentheses are cm perp
squared now I'll separate this into
three terms the first term is DM times d
squared this is an integral over the
body the second term is 2 D and I'm
going to hold off on the integral
because the 2 D is the same for every
piece DM r CM x and the third piece is
integral over the body of DM r I can
since our cm x is that our perp I'll
write it as our perp squared and you can
see that this term is precisely the
moment of inertia about the center of
mass now what I'd like to focus on is
this term in particular DM our cm X that
appears in our integral expression
recall that we defined center of mass we
had the condition that the sum of m j r
c MJ was 0 now for an integral
relationship
this is DM r CM j CM equal to zero so
when you sum up the position of every
object with respect to the vector from
the center of mass to your DM element
zero what does this say in terms of
components in terms of components each
component separately vanishes so we have
the condition that cm x is 0 so that
term is 0
which is precisely this term that's 0
and so we can conclude that is now in
this term where D is the same piece for
every object so we're just pulling out
the total mass so it's M total d squared
and let's remind ourselves that D is the
distance between the two parallel axes
plus the moment of inertia about the
center of mass and this result is called
the parallel axis theorem